in the outer worlds you are given six
companions Parvati
max Felix le Nyoka and Sam some people
use them as pack mules or as support
secondary characters but what if today
we swapped it and we beat the outer
worlds using only companions first is
the stats and then we'll get to the
rules for our attributes were gonna be
going below average in the body very
high in personality and high in average
in the mind the skills were then put
into dialog and leadership to maximize
the inspiration and determination tree
and for the character as usual we like
to do a little bit of roleplay with
every one of these videos and I decided
the roleplay for this video would be
Robert Daly aka Captain de Leon captain
of the USS Callister from Black Mirror
daily was an [ __ ] on the Callister
and his companions would do everything
just like we are doing and both this
game and that episode are set in space
so I'd be stupid not to do this
character already the skills are
reflecting my own physique of being
terrible at dodging and blocking with
them being at 1 or 3 for the skill
probably would be smart to hit the gym
one of these days since the
circumference of my arm is smaller than
the cinnamon stick from the Apple Jacks
commercial but I digress after landing
and killing Hawthorne for the 1,000th
time we meet guard fell him and get our
first gun to which we promptly shoot the
barrels escape and never use again if
you've seen my pacifist playthrough then
you know how this section plays out and
if not then I'm legally required by the
Terms of Service to tell you to go check
out the video and it will be at the end
of this current video or in the I on the
top right right now but for the rules as
this goes by there are no killing only
the companions are allowed to do so I'm
allowed to use their ability since
that's with them and I'm only commanding
them to do so and I can use other
companion commands like attacking a
certain enemy or running to a specific
location other than that it's get to the
end of the game and already the first
issue arises because we simply do not
have a companion but running through all
the enemies and getting to Edgewater you
eventually get Parvati the very first
companion of the game who will be
extremely useful to us in the late game
especially
before that I did some simple quest of
gravesite fees for Silas I had done this
probably a dozen times so this was easy
XP and I didn't even need the quest
marker for me to be able to get this
quest finished we then met with reed
thompson and gained Parvati one
objective complete with the next one
which was going to go through the game
and get an outfit to match the roleplay
this specific outfit is located in
Byzantium and Byzantium is a very long
way from where we are currently so we're
gonna hold on to that for now we then go
to our next companion at vicar max which
you get by after talking with Reed you
talk to Parvati she she says that you
should go talk to max and if you agree
then you can get vicar max as a
companion if you go through his quest
line which is getting you a book we
finally leave the very safely guarded
gates of Edgewater and meet our first
real fights three baby sprats it didn't
go as bad as I thought it would but it
definitely could have been a lot
smoother so we're gonna have to iron
some things out later see what this
playthrough XP wasn't too bad to come by
like with the pacifist playthrough where
I couldn't kill anybody with this
playthrough we could get XP but it
wouldn't be going as quick because we
couldn't kill anybody the companions had
two so I was trying to do as quick quest
as possible we make it to Adelaide in
person and you would think about the
amount of videos that I've done with
this character involved in the video
that I would know how to spell her name
and honestly I still can't to this day
after hearing both sides one going in in
one ear and out the other ear we do some
quests for Thomas and then for max and
we get some other XP for that and then
attempt to run through the plant like a
speedrunner still confusing myself on
which direction to go to get to the
bottom of this place and then flip every
single switch and you guessed it bring
the power back to Edgewater afterwards
we did a couple more side quests like
rescuing zou grabbing a couple people's
fingers praying that Adelaide would
croak maid talk so that she could shut
up and then go back to read combat at
this stage washing too hard requiring
some back-and-forth techniques by
killing one dude leaving them to reset
the aggro and then coming back going one
at a time it was tedious but effective
with pretty much everything taken care
of though we finish edge water and we
for groundbreaker and no time to spare
at groundbreaker is where we meet Felix
and le Felix is very easy all you have
to do is talk to him
le takes some time but it can be really
done very quickly if you do it the
correct way and also we ended up
completing Max's and Parvati's quest
line for the companion completion we
didn't finish it completely but we
definitely completed one of the steps
here max is very simple hack a couple
things and then you just have to talk to
Jun lay for Parvati so very simple XP
here I had no plans on actually fully
completing any of the companion
storylines I just needed the easy XP so
I could get some view levels speaking of
levels currently at this point were
level seven with about sixty in each for
determination and inspiration so we're
almost there we finally meet with Ellie
and find her friend but we got to get
her out so we talked to June late and
let her get acquainted with Parvati now
groundbreakers really simple not much
going on here and the only really big
problem is the Manta pillars and then
the small little robots in the back with
the june lake quest and then the in the
very first quest when you talk to those
guys underneath in the back bay but you
convince them just to let you walk
through so really not too much fighting
going on in here and provide a and max
were able to kill be necessary enemies
very quickly and eventually we have to
decide which side of the game we're
going to complete and at the moment I
ended up picking the board some of those
reasons will be explained a little bit
later so we had to Byzantium to me
adjutant Sophia akan day we do her usual
clash line murdering some boomer and
sawing a Trojan virus and Phineas's
computer you know the usual we then met
Celeste the owner of a nearby clothing
store in Byzantium and she sells the
classic where Umbra which is the outfit
we need I was going to go for the
chimera which many of you may or may not
know is a very unique armor in the game
but it but a it is a very long quest and
B it has red pants on top of it having a
more of a magenta color or a maroon
color whereas captain Daley in black Mir
had a red kind of jacket with black
pants and this fit it perfectly so we
opted to go with this one but the outfit
complete though it's time to conquer the
rest of the colony you probably noticed
that we haven't had too much combat
majority of this playthrough actually we
really didn't run into too much issues
with the combat and then the combat that
we did have was very simple of just
using the the character's abilities and
rummaging through waves and waves of
enemies with ease but that's all gonna
change soon because we go to definitely
not my least favorite planet ever
monarch before also getting Nyoka we
also picked up Sam but I really had no
plans on using Sam I just strictly
wanted to get him just to have him for
the team just like Nyoka and that's
really it
I obviously knew what neo cos ability
was and I personally enjoyed Elly's
ability and the other stuff that she
came with which was her corrosion dagger
and the fact that her abilities actually
helped me a lot with the medical stat
which we'll get to later so I ended up
just telling Nyoka to head back to the
ship and I walked there myself with
Ellie and Parvati by my side like the
simp I am as usual to speed things up
and to take out my anger I usually kill
Graham and Sanjar and I did but I also
kind of didn't see before I left Nyoka I
had her travel with me just to kind of
test out to see if her ability was going
to be useful or not and she ended up
shooting Graham through the floor and
apparently her vibe check wasn't good
enough and I had just run away without
noticing that he was still alive because
I had gotten PTSD from the time I was
doing the kill everybody playthrough and
everyone in the entire area had lit me
up like a candle so I was not getting
anywhere near these people but
apparently he had somehow lived so when
I reached her Reem I noticed that he
didn't die so we had to go all the way
back to finish him off and then also
take a little bit of a detour back to
stellar bay and finish off Sanjar at the
time I was looking at my level being me
level 16 to 18 I thought it was actually
over level than prepared that's why I
ended up rushing through this because
this was unnecessary XP I ran through
all the manta Queens to Devil's Peak
like I said melted the enemies inside of
my dashing captain Powers and made it to
high room after completing monarch we're
at an easy level 18 with a hundred in
every single stat in the leadership
section which is determination and
inspiration meaning we're gonna be
getting massive bonuses from these stats
but we can definitely do a hell of a lot
better because now all we need to do is
level up the medical staff for the
health booster which is one of the
reasons why I kept Ellie with the
medical stat the higher you level up the
more health that you gain when you kill
yourself with the adrenal and there's
also a perk that 30% of that heal can go
to
teammates so the higher the percentage
the more higher that individual number
is and that's the endgame plan that I
had to fight for the RAM boss which we
will see later first we met Minister
Clarke and we continued with the Phineas
side of the game getting the chemicals
and whatnot not really to complete it
but just to get a little bit more XP and
let's just say we turn that lab into a
cemetery
they absolutely tossed the salads of
every single person in that lab it was
disgusting
after getting the chemicals and getting
all the quests in the main story so that
once we got to the hope we could choose
which side we wanted to be on right
there we of course ultimately skip the
hope to Tartarus to do the board ending
after that we got a few more quests and
grabbed over a hundred shots of Adreno I
think we're at a hundred and thirty
hundred and fifty so we go back to
convince the guard to give us the ID
scan and we walk through all the
prisoners and meet Phineas and we start
the RAM boss fight there was this
strategy in my head that I kind of
thought about that may or may not work
and I said that if it didn't work no
problem this is more of a test run to
see how it would go but I actually ended
up killing the RAM boss in like a minute
and a half if that which was brutal all
I really did was have both of my hands
on the keyboard and I just spammed C&V
to get both of their character abilities
to proc every single time that came up
and while I was doing that I was
constantly spamming myself like some kid
with asthma or a drug dealer who got a
new supply I kept inhaling the Adreno
because the help that I was getting was
going to my teammates and even if they
weren't getting shot I had a hundred and
fifty like Adreno to go through so it
wasn't really a big deal cuz those
combat drones can really [ __ ] up your
health bar so my whole purpose was just
to keep spamming it until they ended up
killing the RAM boss and we ended up
doing it in like a minute to a minute
and a half which was way quicker than I
thought this was going to go after they
would do their abilities I had this idea
that we needed shock batons because auto
mechanicals are the most weakest to
shock so that would do the most damage
so after tinkering with those I ended up
giving them those so they would smack
the [ __ ] out of him only using melee no
ranged weapons here and with that
intense healing like I said we were able
to completely destroy this boss in no
time at all thanks to Ellie's medical
stat because we are at a hundred and
twenty four because of her after killing
the RAM we grabbed the keycard and rush
upstairs I was going to do the
traditional three six
but because we couldn't kill anybody I
decided to do the 360 in the air and
have Parvati finish it off with a little
alley-oop assist and absolutely smacked
the everliving [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
corpse and we destroyed phineas and beat
the outer worlds only using companions
this was a interesting run to say the
least it was really tough in the
beginning but got a lot easier the more
I realized what certain stats could use
cuz I never really used the medical stat
throughout the game there is one way
that we can make this a lot better and
if this video gets enough likes and
maybe gets enough support I'll do it
what if we did this same exact idea but
instead of on Normal difficulty
we've crank it up to supernova where the
Companions can actually die let me know
what you guys think about that in the
comments below yeah but is always like
to be if you do enjoy guys subscribe for
free new and with that hope you enjoyed
the video let me know just think about
it in the comments below take care have
a great rest of your week
and peace out I'll see in another video
goodbye
[Music]